speaking of dysfunction the philadelphia
eagles looking for a head coach and
yesterday when doug peterson was fired
they immediately according to
insidethebirds.com reached out to
lincoln riley the oklahoma head coach to
gauge his interest now shireen earlier
today
my theory was
that jeffrey lurie
fired doug peterson knowing full well
who he wants to hire and knowing he was
going to get him
the notion that they're
gauging the interest of lincoln riley
and don't even know whether or not he'd
want it and it's going to undermine the
rest of the search if riley says no
thank you that tells me that maybe they
don't have
their alternative already lined up wink
nod here's the guy that's eventually
going to get the job unless they're
doing the best they can to make it look
like it's a wide open search because you
don't pursue lincoln riley unless you
know you're going to get lincoln riley
and uh and look maybe they end up
getting lincoln riley and maybe the rest
of the search is just aimed at propping
it up but i i i just i have a feeling
now that this was anyone but doug
peterson we have to move on from doug
peterson and then we'll figure out who
the coach is going to be
i agree with you mike in in the
hours after this happened that they
fired doug peterson i was convinced that
they fired doug peterson because they
already had a head coach lined up
whether that was deuce daily or somebody
else they already had somebody in mind
who they wanted and we're going to go
out and make that hire as quickly as
possible i mean i know they have to
comply with the rooney rule but as
quickly as possible make that higher but
you're right when you reach out to
somebody like lincoln riley it's
different than say an assistant coach in
the nfl i mean you better know that you
have a really good chance of hiring him
like jacksonville with urban meyer they
think they have a good shot at hiring so
they basically put their search on hold
until urban meyer makes up his decision
i don't know where they go if urban
meyer doesn't take that job but it's the
same with the eagles you you have to
know or think you know that you can get
lincoln raleigh once you go down that
path
and i i don't see any signs that they're
going to get get lincoln riley but
this is kind of a weird search too mike
with what they're doing and i don't know
what they're doing you know when you
change head coaches i've always said you
better have a better one you better know
you're going to get a better head coach
than what you had that's the only reason
to make that move they better have
somebody in mind that's going to be
better than doug peterson
and this really isn't an attractive job
right now for a variety of reasons last
week i said it's chargers jaguars jets
and the other three head coaching jobs
wait till next year don't take those
jobs too many dynamics working against
you and in philly too many dynamics
working against you two quarterbacks job
number one you've got to have a plan for
which one you want now look if you feel
strongly about either jalen hurts or
carson wentz you got both under contract
for multiple years into the future good
but if you want to go off the board
that's going to make it even crazier and
usually a head coach has an idea of who
he would like to have as his quarterback
unless it's a true short list franchise
quarterback like when tony dungy landed
in indianapolis 19 years ago and peyton
manning was already there you're
thinking who's my quarterback going to
be and so that complicates things the
fan base which is
very demanding and can be very difficult
for a coach to deal with that's a
complicating factor the media there's a
complicating factor and just this sense
of
dysfunction
not as bad as houston i mean again this
is a team that just won a super bowl
three years ago it's it's astounding to
me how quickly it can all fall apart and
you look at the best run teams
and they find a way to keep their coach
they find a way to stay the course
and when you have a coach that took you
to the playoffs three straight years
it better be damn bad there'd better be
proof of an organic personality change
or just people deciding they hate each
other because it's incumbent on everyone
once you've found a formula that can
work
you need to keep
letting it work because like you said
there's no guarantee you're going to
find somebody better there's no
guarantee at all and and i'd love to
know the full story of what happened
between jeffrey laurie howie roseman and
doug peterson because it had to have
been significant to cause jeffrey lurie
to throw out the window
a head coach who had been to the
playoffs three straight years and had
won a super bowl the the only other
teams that have won a more recent super
bowl are the chiefs and the patriots the
other 29 nfl franchises are saying well
we wish we had a coach that won a super
bowl three years ago
you know what else is weird about this
mic yesterday i was convinced that it
had a lot to do with carson wentz that
doug peterson maybe didn't want carson
wentz wanted a different quarterback to
start next season and and those above
him wanted to save carson wentz i was
really convinced of that
but then you go and and make a play for
lincoln riley who coached jalen hurts in
college which that tells me something
totally different now
maybe he wouldn't have jalen hurts as
his starting quarterback but he
obviously knows jalen hurts very well
jalen hurts knows his offense i don't
know the whole thing again to me is very
strange with the timing of of getting
rid of doug peterson moving on because
something happened over the last week i
mean black monday was a week ago mike
and they made the decision yesterday
yeah very very strange situation all
around and even though eagles fans
should be happy that there is a lombardi
trophy that was made not that long ago
in the lobby of the facility it feels
like they are
farther away from winning one than they
were before they won their first one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports